Samsung and LG are two giants in the
electronics world they're also both from
South Korea and their big rivals from
TVs to washing machines they go
head-to-head at CES with their new
offerings every year and this year we
like their futuristic fridges the first
stop is LG their fridge is part of the
design oriented signature range and it's
not exactly a smart fridge it's more
beauty than brains you knock on the
front tinted window twice and it shows
you what's inside maybe your cat got in
there somehow you can also use the foot
sensor to open the door
if your hands are full or covered in
batter LG says this fridge is Wi-Fi
connected but it's more of a premium
design piece Samsung's fridge is quite a
bit smarter the touch screen on the
front of it runs Tizen and it also runs
several apps you can view recipes and
order groceries right on the screen and
your kids can draw on it cameras on the
inside of it beam pictures of your food
to your phone while you're at the store
that way you can see all the old food
rotting in your fridge
there's no price for either of these
fridges yet but we do expect they will
cost a fortune